[Musique]
c'est dans la peinture que donner ses
journées à trouver comment s'exprimer un
besoin de spontanéité l'artiste peint
depuis une trentaine d'années ce qu'elle
ressent des sentiments triste des
sentiments gay un besoin de les partager
dans wii de les montrer de connaître le
regard de l'autre justement à travers
une exposition et donc de me dire tiens
on aime on n'aime pas pourquoi on aime
pas aussi c'est intéressant
tiens je comprends pas ce que c'est
l'idée c'est pas toujours de voir
quelque chose sur une toile c'est de
dire tiens ça me touche parce que voilà
[Musique]
donné ces journées a débuté la peinture
à magny les hameaux
avant les émotions elle couchait sur sa
toile modèle des voyages pour les
émotions elle a choisi l'acrylique
[Musique]
on peut pas tricher avec l'acrylique
parce que une fois que s'est posée sur
la toile s'est posée c'est pas comme
l'huile ça sèche très lentement
l'acrylique en un quart d'heure se sait
que c'est pas du tout la même technique
il faut pas se tromper
après bon il faut travailler les
couleurs par plusieurs étapes c'est tout
un procédé on peut ajouter des coquilles
d'oeuf pourquoi pas du marc de café
c'est marrant c'est ludique l'acrylique
c'est ludique voilà des émotions qu'elle
transmet par des toiles toujours très
coloré une vingtaine d'entre elles
s'exposent à plaisir jusqu'au 16 mars
[Musique]